this week conflicts owners in New York
the Lynne here
Leipzig and O Russell's off Spanish
brexit the euro crisis disagreement
about refugees are we witnessing the
last days of the European Union I don't
believe it up it are the last days of
the European Union but it all may be the
last days of this European Union the
English are the ones who will feel the
damage most its it's almost as if he
wants the British to suffer not as a
result of loss there is no revenge or
less than giving sentiment it is clear
that I mean we fully respect the choice
of the Brits we need now to focus on
what needs to be done
among 27 and notably within the eurozone
and a new investment policy to boost
growth but it would be very good for you
as the British suffered wouldn't it no
why what if they make it what if they
make a go of it what if their economy
grows
what if their employment grows what if
all the economic indicators turn green
how are you going to persuade your
citizens here who are laboring with
eleven and a half percent unemployment
that it's worth staying in the EU now
that makes your job that much harder
doesn't it my job is a very difficult
one a the job of any other British
success would make it even more do I
wish all the success of the breeds I do
not believe I do not believe that there
is the right choice I fully respect the
British choice I think that it is a
deeply wrong choice and I think that in
the medium round
Britain will suffer from that and we
regret it lot of apocalyptic warnings in
the last few days about what brexit will
mean even you said before the referendum
we're looking into the precipice is the
EU so fragile yes it is it's a couple of
years we cannot deny the fact that there
are clear tendencies of dissolution we
have tendencies of lis nationalization
in in many in many countries Germany's
deputy Chancellor Sigma Gabrielle Warren
just days ago that unless the British
exit from the EU was handled properly
the European Union he said would go down
the drain
it's that fragile that you'll go down
the drain I think if you get this way I
think that the Union is going through a
very delicate phase I think that the
Union cannot afford effort to remain in
the status quo and I think the status
quo could be the beginning of European
disintegration whereas what we need is
to relaunch on a new basis the European
integration process is why immediately
we have to give ants for proper ants for
efficient transfer on growth security
and youth and next year we have to think
of a new political pact for the Union
for ever closer Union but these are not
new tablets this you're not saying
anything new that hasn't been you said
you don't need to hustle it hasn't been
said for years you don't need to be
original you just dip implement what we
say what they want to do is to make a
split between these three freedoms and
the freedom of movement of people and we
shall never accept that the unity of the
four freedoms for all citizens is a key
element in example it is negotiating and
saying we will never accept that so
where are the negotiations now we will
never accept to undo the European Union
you cannot expect that if the British
people or majority of the British people
want to go out of the European Union
that we shall destroy European Union I
have to defend the interests of European
citizens but I have to defend the
interests of the German citizens the
Belgium citizens who want to keep the
European Union because it's in their
advantage that lets this European you
talk it's their work is a job you think
that's a clear danger the European Union
will not survive yes absolutely and
other countries will leave yes yes I can
give you the candidates I mean the
Netherlands Italy Austria is the reason
why I want to change every form Europe
this Europe cannot work because member
states have mainly all the powers you
want an issue
and the change is the change is that we
need a real European government what we
don't have for the moment that doesn't
mean a commercial let's talk about now
and that you need to change Europe I
bomb UK from national alternative for
Germany doesn't the growth of national
movements show that the idea of the U is
failing no it's a test for the idea we
have to give answers to the question
than certainly their people because of
internal and external security
consequences of globalization that part
of our society feel that they will fall
down in the workers class and in the
middle classes party but the board has
come both in breaks it as in the pen and
I've tasted the same type of voters like
it is in Trump attends and failures of
the EU of an excellent service to any
populace to wants to create an angry and
right-wing how I can contradict you it's
the reality
but the reality can it's it's very good
that you say yeah this situation this
European Union are you a doesn't
possibly a rise of all these populist
groups yes I know who is responsible a
European Union that doesn't work very
well
creates automatically populism image so
there so there's a usability yes or no
so the only way to react to this is not
to fall into the trap of nationalism and
and populism but is to reform the
European Union the fastest as possible
that is what I'm saying there I am
saying that the only way to fight
against nationalism and populism is to
reform the European Union and if you
don't do it we're going to see in every
member state of the European you in
France in the Netherlands in every
member states a rise of nationalism and
populism and we have the duty to tell to
the popular the public opinion and if
you don't yeah i understood i this
european union doesn't work don't fall
in the trap of nationalist and populist
between you in a few months
there are elections in France and the
pen is today one of the favourites
what will this have for consequences
if after the brexit France will be lead
by a president Madame Le Pen who is
right-wing who is a racist party and an
anti European party if a country like
France would go in such a direction it
would be disaster for France and all of
Europe what means a disaster for Europe
and France it means to go into the past
bond back to nationalism it means that
the old anti feelings of Nations will
increase again and that we go back to
that time before the war that Europeans
fight each other and not attraction
eanes it would be the end of the
European Union
I believe so that a country like France
would do that it would be a major threat
in such a hurry you said the day after
the election of Donald Trump that you
gave them credit for saying he tried to
bind the wounds of division and be the
president for all Americans which is
what they all say I guess how is anybody
supposed to ever believe a word Donald
Trump says after the kind of campaign
we've seen well you don't have to
believe everything you just have to see
what's going to happen I think that's
really the question anyway you know we
look with every presidential candidate
there's always that moment when
presidential campaign rhetoric has to
turn into presidential policy and that's
I think what we're all waiting to see
this is a campaign that rattled lies
didn't it rather quite significant lies
in particular the one that so.2d
legitimize America's first black
president saying that he hadn't actually
been born in the US when it was quite
clear that he had this went on for years
this is this is serious lying isn't it
well the series is in a very very very
divisive campaign and my advice is that
he's got to take steps to rebuild the
center he's right to criticize
Washington over its partisanship an
inability to forge compromises it was
right to run an Isis campaign he's a
he's a deal maker and let's see now if
he can make some deals in Washington he
ran a racist campaign General Jim I'm
done partisan I understand
I'm asking you how you began pain is
over talk but this wasn't a campaign
this is the man isn't it the man ran a
racist campaign how do you get over that
when mr. Trump would be the President of
the United States what is your opinion
about that this has to seen rather than
the vest on Alliance has still the full
credibility that the United States
misters were wrong credible in my
opinion no he's not has not the
credibility but it has a chance to prove
it I'm not going to get into
characterizations of this candidate er
that candidate let's see what President
Trump does let's see who president elect
Trump picks for his cabinet officials
let's see what policies begin to emerge
that so it doesn't shock you I'm 60
million Americans voted for someone who
had lied so comprehensively to them
during the campaign what is it what was
that say well let me tell you what
actually let me tell you what the
election says and that is that the
Washington elite if you will the elite
of the the coasts New York and LA at
lost touch with an awful lot of America
the so called flyover zones the
heartland and that's what came out and
voted in droves
that is what had legitimate concerns
that were tapped into by a campaign that
was very very effective only 60 million
Americans don't care that they were
liked like to compare you have in the
course of their the 60 million general
trust by that
I thought you see in the United States
is one of the presidential candidates
Donald Trump who says NATO is obsolete
and is costing us a fortune and he's
accused Washington's NATO allies of
ripping off the US and says either they
pay up for past deficiencies or they
have to get out and if it breaks up NATO
it breaks up NATO this man could be
present could be president-elect in less
than a week's time I earn and this is
this is a fundamental challenge to
NATO's core existence that you have to
deal with
I absolutely certain that the United
States will understand that also the
future a strong NATO is not only in the
interest of your theory on the basis of
war but also what doctors say so in the
interest of the United States I will not
be part of the US election in a campaign
but what I can say is we won't even
stand up for NATO no other if you don't
need to interrupt me I'm able to finish
my sentence because I what I can say is
what matters for NATO and that is that
we are defending each other that we our
security guarantees are not conditioned
they are absolute we don't say that we
only protect you if you pay we defend
and protect all eyes without any
conditions but then of course I would
like NATO allies to invest more in
defence and that's exactly what they
have started to do and I welcome that
are you worried that NATO is not going
to survive Trump's presidency I'm not
worried about that what I am worried
about is that the cooperation and the
working together that has characterized
this alliance which is so important now
given various threats around the world
that that could be eroded now let me say
by the way once again he has been on to
something that is legitimate secretary
gates in his final session with the
North Atlantic Council I was there as
the commander of the forces in
Afghanistan said to all of them you are
not paying your fair share you're not
meeting the 2% of GDP threshold in your
defense spending now that has improved
in recent years because of some of the
threats that are emerging in various
places but this coalition matters it's a
cornerstone of American security policy
as a cornerstone of the Western world
security policy so again I'm hopeful
that the element of his comments that is
correct that others need to do more that
they need to bear more of the burden
that they will step up to that and
indeed we can we can forge a continued
cooperative effort as we go forward you
have said the European military
coalition is indispensable for the
security of our citizens and will be the
start of a real foreign and defence
community in Europe this means in the
European army doesn't it
exactly yeah we are working on that here
doesn't NATO guarantee European defence
yeah but it's not in contradiction NATO
is a cooperation transatlantic and it's
clear that we need a strong European
defence community inside NATO because
the Americans mr. Obama have said it in
Hannover a few months ago said very
clearly that there are limits to what
the American army will do in Europe and
what he said is Europeans have to take
their own responsibilities hey in the
nation as they said in the Warsaw summit
July earlier this year
Russia has breached the values
principles and commitments which
underpin the NATO Russia relationship
broken the trust at the core of our
cooperation and challenge the
fundamental principles of the global and
euro-atlantic security architecture
that's why I retire this language of
course this is a disadvantage very
familiar to me but at the same time what
we face now this is a huge deviation for
following all the principles we agreed
before this is the basic principle of
indivisibility of security what we face
now that there are two levels of
security NATO says that only NATO could
really guarantee security and defence of
the member states and that means that
this all European project is not in
question saying that they're saying the
ongoing illegal and
ultimate annexation of Crimea which NATO
does not and will not recognize and
which they call on Russia to reverse
their calling on Russia to reverse it
for that's what so that's what they say
they're asking for predictability a
little bit once a year see people in
Crimea made their church and this with
full stop
I think that also we need a number of
sanctions in the case of the Syrian
question because this cannot continue
what Russia is doing sanctions against
Russia over Ukraine okay and were
useless nothing changed them would why
would it be now I don't agree with you
it's an attempt that to push and to put
pressure on put in to apply the Minsk
agreement that is what we are trying to
do in the east of a pray and if we don't
continue on that line if we are not
tough against snouted what he gonna do
is to take yeah but not only the east of
Ukraine not enough isn't it the view
from the outside world is rather
different because Biden said very
angrily and he warned your president and
the strongest possible terms he needs to
start living up to the promises of
economic and political reforms or risk
seeing the EU countries and he spoke
about five countries ready to walk away
from sanctions on Moscow if you don't
live up to these I'm not to tell let's
not let's not message around because I
wasn't the last meeting between our
president Andrew Biden where he said
straighten up and fly right my my
sister-in-law can fly right sanctions
sanctions is about Russia waging the war
the hybrid war against Ukraine having
occupied Crimea and heaven actually
occupied Dumba's and sanctions are here
about to get Russia out of Ukraine you
are concerned about Russia you have
talked about the dangerous whims of lad
Amir Putin but Putin has managed to farm
all over I'm on the blacklist of let me
put in this as more than that
okay so whatever but they're our friends
in the European Union
Budapest Athens what can you do about
that now I think there is a very clear
stance and a unity of view in Europe
towards the threat of Vladimir Putin and
that doesn't mean that we have to be
anti Russia I think that we have to
intensify or relationship with the
Russians to give for example you have
relationship with governments I mean
don't know value time I know I don't
agree with you you can develop a number
of policies in Europe who is a country
with whom are you negotiating with with
the people or with the ground with a
civil society and at the same time with
the government and the civil society you
can help them why not for example get a
free visa to Russian students to roughen
a Russian scientist that needs to be
done but we have to be very tough
towards the Russian government two words
put it because it's very clear that he
is still a product of the Soviet Union
and not of everything what happened
after the fall of the Berlin Wall
it's my fundamental point security
should be there and Russia should be out
in order to get Dumba's back into
Ukraine and they mean Ukrainian Dumba's
integrate and not create again a kind of
great and big transmission so phenomenal
is dead not at all
you were speaking that people in the
whole of the United Nations
representatives and government
facilitated planned and carried out
atrocity who do you mean was fashion
I have Russell I have asked several
times to the Security Council of the
United Nations to read for this case to
International Criminal Court so that
this International Criminal Court should
make their legal and judicial tracking
since Russia know this I'm referring
this Sicilian case to ICC nobody knows
silence about I have an a so-called by
Russia why because they are member of
the Security Council I have been I have
been expressing my concern about the
division of the Security Council where
Russia is also part of the member when
Russia began the major operations in
Syria it gave the US air force one hour
to get out of the skies that was how
little they thought of them but again I
think we have to submit our detail
standard difference between NATO's
responsibilities which is the fund
protect all allies and we are doing that
and we provide credible deterrence every
day we have seen no attack military
attack against any NATO ally for almost
70 years
then of course NATO is also concerned
about what is going on outside the old
our borders all NATO allies participate
in the coalition fighting ISIL NATO as
an alliance provide direct support to
the larger lines fighting ISIL with our
Air Act's surveillance planes in Aleppo
we are doing our utmost efforts United
States and Russia they are also working
very hard even though Russians working
hard at complain and their relationship
has been a little bit sensitive now I'm
I have urged the secretary Kerry and
Russian side to restore the cessation of
hostilities so that we can deliver
life-saving humanitarian
we have been delivering minimum minimum
and at average more than 5 million
people who are in besieged areas and
hard-to-reach areas and we have air
dropped to a list of more than 1 million
people look unless they are doing almost
airport under such a very very difficult
situation the most senior Human Rights
official in the United Nations the
Commissioner High Commissioner for Human
Rights has accused your forces of war
crimes in Syria do you care what he
thinks
well first of all I would like to say
that situation in Syria is very
worrisome and you know that from the
beginning Russia Federation was one of
the countries who struggle for political
and peaceful solution understand that
but I'm talking about war crimes and no
more than three section there is no
there is no of course we care about
everything but at the same time you
should know what we are doing in Syria
and what was the policy of the Russian
Federation as I said first of all we'll
launch the political process and Geneva
process was a result of Russian efforts
and you should admit it and we did a lot
to stop the war in Syria you know that
we play critical role in the drawing of
all chemical weapons from from Syria
understand how to not use the
indiscriminate airstrikes of course you
know you know the lepor you're accused
of indiscriminate air strikes across a
leper by government forces and their
allies which you are responsible for the
overwhelming majority of civilian
casualties I'm asking you to address
that I'm I'm asking which comes from the
most senior official Human Rights
official of the United first of all I
would like to refer to the actions that
were taken by the Russian Federation
quite recently for three days for three
days there was a ceasefire established
by the Russian armed forces with a view
to allow people to live
lapin mr. Esther Nalepa and you know by
the way that in western part of the city
the overall amount of population is more
than 1 million and they suffered very
much from assaults from the terrorist
groupings Jeff cotton Uttara and others
I understand but you don't want to
address these these charges do you the
British prime minister Theresa May said
last week it's vital we work together to
continue to put pressure on Russia to
stop it's appalling it's sickening
atrocities in Syria German Chancellor
Angela Merkel what Russian what is
happening with Russian support in Aleppo
is completely inhuman you don't answer
the I'm not charge
I am answer I'm answering your question
by saying that what we are doing in
Syria first of all we are promoting
peaceful process political process and
we encourage de Mistura to re-engage in
political discussions about the future
of Syria and secondly we are fighting -
to fight - this is fully in accordance
with international law and bombing the
civilian population we are intimately
there they were not bombing civilian
populations there are not a guarantee I
am NOT talking categorically of course
maybe there is a collateral damage is
the UN and alibi are you as a
secretary-general were you an alibi for
those who didn't respect human rights
who killed people who didn't respect the
needs of the refugees we are the first
responders always and helper and
rescuers of those people who are in need
of a support we are trying to provide
life-saving support whether it is a
humanitarian or any security protection
I am conscious of sometimes lack of
support such kind of thing norm as a
speedy as effective responded to that
but you should also understand the
circumstantial difficulties lack of
political will on the part of member
state that a lot of
political props which make our work they
are very difficult I'm urging member
state to fully abide by human rights
principles and values of the United
Nations after imagination exists for the
people we are serving the people's
around the world
you